from The Daily Mail
White House cocaine was found near the
situation room and not in the West Wing
visitor entrance drug story changes for
the second time as secret service now
says Dimebag was found in a more secure
location okay so it was Hunter right
yeah I mean I I struggle to imagine
anyone else who was just sneaking in
cocaine to the White House because I
would imagine I've never been there but
I imagine they have pretty good security
I imagine there are cameras I imagine
people getting searched yeah we're the
cameras I bet anything it was Jill
doctors
railing of what the video of Hunter on
on the balcony yeah it kind of looks
like he's kind of strung out he's you
know well then he goes a picture of uh
let me actually let me pull this out
this video is great he goes behind Jill
and it looks like he pulls his sleeve up
takes a bump off his arm and it also
looks like Jill is furious which I mean
if your son was strung out you probably
would be like if she can sense him
behind her and she's just in a mood
she's like this guy not in a mood
in a mood because of the right term take
a look at this picture Victor she
tweeted wow this photo of President
Biden sitting on the White House steps
is just so breathtaking and captures
this moment so well Joe Budden is doing
so much for all of us and has the weight
of the world on his shoulders and I just
want to say thank you every time I see
him so here's this here's the support
not a sentiment that I get and uh the
sentiment I got from this was Joe sat
down
looked at the Horizon and went damn that
was my Coke
like he's like damn it you Hunter you
can't just go I got it 45 minutes
without blowing lines up your nose I
said he was thinking something like that
you know Hunter he's I wonder if I don't
know if you can I assume a lot from a
picture but I imagine that Joe's just
like so broken about what he has be like
what happened with Hunter and and the
world knows there's video of Hunter like
there's pictures off his laptop with
little young people like chill kids well
that's what's crazy about the whole
Hunter Biden story not necessarily that
he's into all of this depravity but it's
that he feels the Apparently compulsive
need to document all of it like I mean
I've never seen a man take so many
incriminating selfies in my whole life
you know I understand it though because
in ice skateboard and so we're always
trying to film everything we do to make
sure everybody knows just you know how
good we are at skateboarding and how
good you are at the cracks like well
here's the thing man you know Hunter
Biden is a big part of the crack
community and he wants to make sure
everybody knows he's the best if you're
that good at smoking crack you want
people to know you know he goes to his
body and he's like yo I need to film her
because we're going to be doing cracking
prostitutes later tonight someone's got
to capture this stuff and they're like I
just use your phone put on Instagram and
he's like all right I was thinking about
like the Roman Republic or the Roman
Empire really how they would have like
these giant parties and on boats like
when it was all falling apart there's
just these decadent things and then we
see this Festival of Joe Biden just like
vacantly staring out his wife not even
looking at his son who's a crackhead who
just got like not pardoned but like a
misdemeanor for having like crack and a
gun on him and the how they'll look back
at this period of history at that and be
like wow what did America become that
the first son was like just given a
little pat on the wrist for having
something that would have thrown other
people yeah yeah I left his response to
that was that it's actually it's because
of white privilege nothing to do with
Joe Biden and Corruption because of that
it's specifically because Hunter is
white because all white people would
have been treated the same and and Ian
it very very it may very well be that in
a hundred years the way they look back
on this moment is it was the beginning
of the Fall
yeah um I think the Kennedy
assassination was there they they they
perhaps will write in the future and say
kids ah there's always something the
first fall of the American Empire
started in what date and they're going
to be like July 4th 2023 and what caused
it finding Hunter Biden's cocaine that's
right kids it is pretty nasty it's like
what kind of faith can you have I mean
it obviously power this is what I've
always been told they they protect each
other people in power nepotism runs
rampant and they flaunt it and I think
this is Hunters flaunting it obviously
with all his pictures and a propaganda
and then Joe's just completely ignoring
it and saying he's my son well they said
they found it near the West executive
entrance I think it's a lie officials
visitors and celebrities yeah I don't
believe yeah next thing you know they're
going to be like at first there was a
library then that was The West Wing Now
situation room we found it we found it
on Biden we literally found it in his
pocket or they'll say it was something
other than cocaine next they'll be like
it was actually baked baking soda we
thought it was coke it wasn't
I mean what what a bunch of crap why
would they even tell us anyway why would
they even bring this up who because they
don't they don't want they want to
replace Biden
they're getting rid of a mic drop I
think you're right dude yeah it's
probably gonna be Newsome or something
yeah well he's he's going on a
nationwide tour he was doing some uh
something I think it was in Idaho and
Boise where he was uh visiting a
bookstore like oh look at these banned
books it's like you're at a bookstore
the books are not banned if they're at a
bookstore but I mean there's no reason
he's doing anything outside of
California unless he wants to run for
president what do you think about
Michelle Obama
um I think so she doesn't really have
the experience or the gravitas that
Barack did but there's a lot of
nostalgia around the Obama presidency
for I think like a lot of Independence
probably disaffected liberals so I think
I mean if it's her or Kamala definitely
Michelle Obama yeah yeah but the truth
is if you're
if if you have Nostalgia for Obama you
didn't pay attention to Obama's
presidency oh yeah I'm not denying that
but I think there are like a lot of
disaffected liberals or people who would
not vote Democrat now who were happy to
vote for Obama regardless of how things
were going just because it it felt nice
you know he he felt like a president and
it was the good old days back then even
it though it wasn't in a lot of ways
partly why some people probably voted
for Biden yeah because they were thought
it was going to be like Obama or
whatever but it's probably going to be
Newsome we'll see though I mean I really
don't know it's it's worth it I feel
like that would be such a hard sell
because you are governor of a state that
is bleeding hemorrhaging people it's
it's it's just going down the drain who
on Earth would look at California and
think yes more of this if you it's you
know there are people who live in these
places yeah and they keep defending
what's going on it's remarkable when we
have a conversation with some of these
liberals people live in New York and
it's like 25 people were pushed in front
of subway trains last year like that's
bad and they're like so what and I'm
like you don't have we don't I'm not
arguing every single person in Manhattan
is falling in front of trains I'm saying
you probably should do something to stop
this from happening yeah well I think
what's frustrating about talking to
people from New York and California
especially is that they act like those
things are normal like I remember there
was uh oh gosh what it was with Jordan
Neely right uh this homeless guy was
threatening people there are so many New
Yorkers who are saying well that's just
normal that's an everyday occurrence he
didn't need to freak out I was like what
is the matter with you people you don't
need to live like this there are so many
other places even other cities where
this doesn't happen stop defending it
and it's also frustrating because these
are the people who by and large hate
America the most and it's like you are
in a blue City in a blue State when the
president is a Democrat if things aren't
going well perhaps step back and take a
look at why that is I'm kind of excited
for everything that's going on with
politics because I'm feeling like you
know we're winning with with the Bud
Light stuff especially and I do think
we're going to start to see more liberal
personalities start adopting the
disaffected liberal stances on things
because at a certain point they're going
to realize
they there's no market for the weird
leftist stuff
I mean I'll put it this way
eight years ago it was intersectional
feminism you know critical race Theory
now it's wokeness gender ideology it
keeps whatever like what it keeps
changing what the left wants they have
they have no position it's just random
and amorphous at a certain point as they
keep getting crazier and more unhinged
with what with whatever it is they're
supporting
people are leaving Liberals are becoming
disaffected and that means these
commentators are going to lose their
positions and they're going to be forced
to be like okay that's too much for me I
think people are starting to wake up
because I follow this is just a very
anecdotal thing but I follow a lot of
makeup brands on things like Instagram
just because you know it's it's fun it's
girly whatever but during pride month
it's insufferable every makeup Beauty
brand any brand that caters to women
they're all out trans this uh let's put
men in our products whatever I started
actually looking through the comments
because I was just unfollowing Brands
because I'm sick of it I started looking
through the comments expecting this is
brave like you know because by and large
women at least on social media they all
eat that stuff up but no overwhelmingly
people were fed up saying unfollow what
does this have to do with the product
and I think that's a good like even
normies are getting sick of it normies
who are probably left right women are
getting turfy like I literally just just
this morning I got a text message from a
buddy of mine who's in a very well-known
band and he's like he's me a a tweet
from from Jill flipovic and she was
talking about you know about how
marriages are are not you know people
aren't getting married in there and they
don't last and and she was looking at
this as a as a victory because she
thinks that women are out there doing
what they want to do and living their
lives even though everybody it seems
that people are more depressed and not
happy about it but anyways she was
looking at it as a as a victory in my
buddy's like do you believe this stuff
and I'm like look
this is this is kind of how the the left
go goes they don't actually embrace
things like family values and he's you
know he's he's got a family and he's
talking about his his wife and he's like
she's he's like you know she's kind of
turfy and stuff and and I was like look
the she was talking about women and uh
men in in women's bathrooms and stuff
and that's where the line is being drawn
women want to have their own spaces yeah
you could probably get away with
bathrooms maybe you're not gonna get
away with locker rooms you're not
getting away with dudes with with trans
women in the G in the gym locker room
walking around with a boner look at the
Wii Spa remember yeah exactly it's
exactly so that turned out to actually
not be a trans person it was just a guy
who liked flashing his junk at women and
so because of these policies and it's
funny because conservatives are like
what's going to stop a man from doing it
or whatever and they're all like the
left says trans people don't do these
things like right we're concerned about
the men doing it under the guise yeah so
what happens is this dude goes in the
women's locker room flashing his junk
and when a woman complains they're like
must be a trans person so we're not
going to do anything about it then it
turns out to be a repeat offender they
arrest if they if it is a trans person
or if it is a trans person they do
something imagine what they're gonna get
on social media the backlash the either
you're transphobic Etc all the all of
the incentive is to allow the person in
the bathroom to do whatever it is that
they want just as long as they don't
actually physically grab someone else
because the repercussions of being wrong
or being accused of being transphobic
suicide let me tell you guys something
the uh first ever 1080 on a skateboard
was done by I think a 12 year old boy
12. this is like pre-pubescent it's like
there's no you know they say puberty is
the is the point or whatever
the 12 year old boy this tremendous feat
where are the females
if puberty is what matters so recently a
I think a 12 year old girl did the first
ever 720 on avert ramp 720 okay so for
those not familiar with this what this
means when you spin a full rotation
around it's a 360 you're spending 360
Degrees you did that twice at 720 you do
three times to 1080. just this in this
past week or so a a 12 year old girl did
a 720 annivert ramp the first time a
girl's ever done it it was a huge deal
everyone's screaming and cheering and I
find it duplicitous
to celebrate the first female to do a
720 at the same time they're celebrating
males competing in women's sports
you recognize the the literal
distinction between males and females
because if it really was that there it
doesn't matter if you're male or female
they would have been like who cares that
a female did a 720 a 12 year old boy did
a 1080 and then I think another guy did
a 1260 a couple years ago which was
really real big deal
but the reality is because they know
females are not competing at the same
level as males what's going to happen
when we've already had uh if you guys
have been following Taylor Silverman who
actually works here she was competing
skateboarding contest and had lost
contests to biological males
how can this contradiction exist but
I'll tell you
the frustrating thing about it
people in the skateboard industry at the
highest levels will privately privately
say yeah we're not okay with this stuff
and then publicly be like Yay good for
you
that's starting to change yeah and
that's the cultural shift we're saying
and I'm actually happy to see because
now people are finally being like okay
we can't keep doing this but what's
Insidious is that on the left I've
already seen the next evolution of their
argument it's like At first of all
there's no difference you don't you
don't need to worry about men uh taking
over women's sports because they don't
have an advantage now it's like okay
they do have an advantage but that is
exactly why kids need to go on puberty
blockers it's so that the advantage
isn't I guess instilled but that that is
BS because at least according to my
pediatrician or my kids pediatrician
from birth boys and girls are on
different growth charts from from
conception men and women are different
actually in in utero right prenatal
testosterone has a big impact on fast
fast twitch muscle development for
instance um listen I don't think that
children should be put on puberty
blockers until they're old enough to
decide what gender they want to be but I
want the left to make that argument real
bad I want them to make that argument
real bad because they will die at The
Ballot Box regarding like winning like
right now that the call it feels like
things have changed like there's a a sea
change and whether it's a winning it's
like an ingredient of winning it's like
the Anvil is so hot right now we have
heated this system up by uncovering the
problems and Hyper focusing on them and
teaching people about the problems now
it is hot now it is time to strike and
that is to create some sort of cultural
revolution that is in the mind easy with
with those kind of well this is what
mountains
and pull in the cultural revolution talk
but that's what's happening right now
and we have to guide it no no Evolution
that's happening regardless of whether
you want it or not the question is is
the outcome going to be preferable to
you yes and we need we need to push back
against the people that are trying to
have a cultural revolution in the US
because the cultural revolution is in a
an illiberal Direction what we want is
we want liberal principles in America
and right now the push in the cultural
revolution is an authoritarian push it's
where the censorship comes from it's
where the shutting people down comes
from all that stuff is authoritarian and
it's illiberal and it's not what we want
but we need a new way of of living life
in the okay for instance kids are seeing
porn at the age of nine we need some
sort of sexual education Revolution no
no no we need to uphold the laws as
they've been forever you can't just I
mean if you just
so I cut you off sorry you said we need
to have a sexual education for
nine-year-olds no what needs to happen
is it has always been illegal to allow
children into adult movie stores and
bookstores Etc sure and then one day the
internet internet gets invented and then
everyone in our in our country just goes
now it's fine well no no no it's not
fine websites that allow children to
access that stuff should be prosecuted
the same way a bookstore with a pair
it's the parents that are allowing it
that's the problem yeah but it you could
say it's the parents that are allowing
it when it comes to pornography but if a
little kid were to go into us into a
supermarket and buy alcohol you wouldn't
just say oh it's the parents that need
to do it no yeah but the parents let
them do it but it would still be illegal
to sell alcohol to that minor regardless
of what the parents wanted or not why is
there a different standard for online
pornography because that's also not the
standard for in-person pornography
thanks for watching this clip from the
timcast IRL podcast hang out with us
live Monday through Friday at 8pm and
become a member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time